iba en camino hacia los restos del
Titanic cuando el sumergible titán de
Ocean Gate expeditions desapareció y con
él las cinco personas a bordo el piloto
y cuatro pasajeros que pagaron
250.000 dólares por persona para
acercarse al pedazo de historia que
representa el Titanic el sumergible una
nave similar a un submarino pero más
pequeña y con menos potencia partió
desde saint-jones en la mañana del
domingo y emprendió un viaje de 640
kilómetros hacia el fondo del océano
antes de perderse
es una zona muy remota y es un reto
llevar a cabo una búsqueda en una zona
tan remota
pero estamos desplegando todos los
medios disponibles para asegurarnos de
que podemos localizar la embarcación y
rescatar a las personas a bordo
[Música]
entre los miembros de la tripulación
Además del capitán se encuentra el
multimillonario británico James jarding
en estos momentos las principales
hipótesis de lo sucedido son dos que el
sumergible haya perdido la comunicación
pero siga en funcionamiento o que haya
tenido un accidente según los expertos
las personas a bordo cuentan con un
Rango de 70 a 90 horas restantes de
oxígeno
Sí es muy preocupante tendrá algo de
aire de reserva en botellas comprimidas
y cosas por el estilo pero solo durará
un tiempo determinado para muchos es
inevitable hacer comparaciones entre la
suerte que corrió el famoso Titanic a
cuando se hundió en 1912 y la del
submarino aunque los expertos aseguran a
una y esperanzas y posibilidades reales
de encontrarlos a con vida